hey everyone welcome to Abby's kitchen
today I'm gonna be thinking outside the
user manual showing you some unorthodox
applications for some my everyday
kitchen tools let me show you what I
mean
exhibit a the coffee filter okay so
let's just say you got a little bit
antsy trying to get that expensive
bottle of Merlot open and you actually
showered the cork it's easy to get
excited I get it but I assure you the
party's not over just pour your wine
through a funnel lined with a coffee
filter straight into to canter and
strain out any unwanted impurities it's
best to be discreet about this of course
but you know if someone goes catch you
in the act you can just make something
up about it
aroma ties in your wine you might even
start a trend or something Exhibit B the
ice cube tray so definitely always
seemed like whenever you want ice there
isn't any and by the time you've gone to
the trouble of filling this thing and
freezing it
you've already schlepped home a whole
bag from the grocery store well don't
worry there is use for this piece of
plastic next time you open a large can
or make a big batch of homemade soup or
pasta sauce rather than clumsily
freezing all the leftovers in just one
big resealable bag you can pour it into
your ice cube tray pop it in the freezer
until frozen and then put your frozen
cubes in a freezer bag that way you get
to take out just the portion you intend
to enjoy and you don't end up wasting
your culinary masterpiece because you
have to thaw out an entire bag and
Exhibit C the bundt pan so let's face it
we've probably all bought one of these
and used it once because we realize that
bundt cakes are only marginally
delicious fresh corn on the other hand
now that's always exciting well I do
love a good barbecue table there are
times that I just want to remove the
kernels so I can throw them into a super
salad and now I've seen people trying to
get the kernels off quite awkwardly
hacking at it this way but you know it
just makes me nervous fingers are good
people let's let's keep them
and all that delicious juice all over
the cutting board that's good too so if
you just drop your pop into the bundt
pan you can slide your knife down the
shaft like this it is a lot more secure
this way and you can collect all the
juices and kernels in one place so there
you have it three new and innovative
ways to use those tools you've probably
got collecting dust in a drawer thanks
so much for joining me for today's
gastronomic adventure be sure to check
back regularly for upcoming episodes
Bobbi's kitchen where nothing says lovin
like something from the other